hey guys Ryan right in the hizzy and
Jerry yeah you gotta be more confident
sometimes my friend Jerry
hahaha the reason people tune into these
shows obviously so today we're checking
out a clip from Jurassic world called
Owen escapes the indominus rex paddock
oh [ __ ] I caught this clip already I
filmed the reaction but then the mic
wasn't on again yeah it is always the
best thing to encounter it's my favorite
Jerry has not seen it yet no I haven't
but so that way this video is more
interesting for you guys
Jerry yes we'll be giving a real
reaction I will sure step it up I'll
make sure to actually you know a moat
more than necessary because I know
that'll piss a lot of you off and I'm
faking it so let's do this I'll try not
to talk over the clip too much for you
thanks man I hoped I just hope this is
better that's good oh well I don't want
to ruin anything for you you sound
really I am so excited for this clip
yes oh hey Jake Shawn close the door
we can't lock at me I want telecom
somebody talk to me what is happening
oh so intense so intense like 35 seconds
so edge-of-your-seat I mean I feel like
it'll be a cooler the big screen and
with an entire scene wrapped around it I
got a major problem with that scene what
very first time I saw it I was like that
dude who's a dick and spider-man is also
kind of maybe a dick in this movie what
no one knows who you're talking about
the indominus rex this is a hybrid
dinosaur uh-huh it's supposed to be the
most lethal [ __ ] on the planet
right now
I remember in Jurassic Park 1 people
were driving in a Jeep
Jeff Goldblum was like let's go for Ford
Jeff Goldblum was like them you must go
faster must go faster and the t-rex
caught up with them and almost murder
them because it kept trying to knock the
car over with its head how the [ __ ] this
Chris Pratt possibly outrun this
dinosaur because it was too busy eating
the other guy it picked up the other guy
swallowed him and then just was like a
foot behind him the whole time
there is no way Chris Brackett Avella if
a Jeep cannot out run a [ __ ] t-rex
there's no way it's gonna be like we
created this hybrid dinosaur but it's
slower than a t-rex you're not gonna do
that
fair enough yeah that's fair criticism
yeah and what do you guys are gonna be
like it's just a summer blockbuster it's
just entertainment
gosh this plane your disbelief like you
know what that is - II logically [ __ ]
up there's no way he would escape that
dinosaur okay here are two things one I
mean suspension of disbelief yeah is
like you do still have to make the world
match itself you're good jumping up to a
singular plane it's like mm-hmm
there has to be consistency even if
first spend disbelief
however who is on 35 second clip like I
stuck things like this I'm like cool
someone's gonna get chased I still need
to see the movie to understand the list
thanks for the clip guys it's really
instilled confidence in me yeah
right I don't have a problem with its
it's another one of those things are
only yeah is still gonna see the movie
these trailers [ __ ] rock these clips
get me worried yeah I'm less worried
about this than the other one though I'm
like well there's no like actual [ __ ]
dialog going on under the eyes this
dinosaur they say is incredibly smart
but it won't checked it if they won't
check under the Jeep I don't know we
have to wait and see oh yeah he'll check
under the Jeep and Chris Pratt will run
away just in time I don't know yeah
you're really angry you seem like you
really don't like this movie alright
because it just breaks the rules too
much man you don't well I don't know
like again you need a whole movie like
like this is the problem I think was
releasing so many clips like this is
like we start to read really heavily
into not much I think look I don't think
you're getting what I'm saying here
buddy I do you make a valid point and I
don't know Jurassic Park why yeah does
Chris Pratt run faster than a Jeep it's
not in Jurassic purple but can he run
faster than GP thing no no he cannot
and that dinosaur doesn't need it like
yeah but I use a fork and knife to eat
the other guy perhaps was that dinosaurs
not going at full sprint right now like
you are you're being too harsh Ryan
being too hard yeah what I don't think
you're being too hard it just seems like
you really don't like this and you're
against it glad I am sit up for the fake
reaction and now these emotions feel
amped up yeah you seem like you're just
really against this probably to feel bad
after we're done recording anyway guys
are going to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects I'm sure
you'll want to now cuz every one of you
guys like check out this clip it's
awesome and I guess I don't agree wanted
to share with you just because we like
it out of the kindness of our hearts
because we want to make you like it -
yeah and you can check out Jerry's
playlist where he does movie reviews on
there reasons - jerr-bear and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where it is so much fun blah
blah blah yeah we're
okay we want product placement we want
product placement
Tyrone wants 1 million subscribers you
want private place boom that's simple
just a bunch of pictures of us like
Pepsi that would be so cool to make like
twenty five thousand dollars off of that
now every trailer reaction just starts
like hey Ryan would you pass me an ice
cold Pepsi Cola